our Focus right now is on recovering it
obviously uh three aircraft shot down
this weekend I don't know if this past
weekend do we have no idea whether this
is a pattern or whether these are
connected
well I think obviously there is some
sort of pattern in there the fact that
we are seeing this uh in a significant
degree over the past week is a cause for
uh interest and and uh uh close
attention uh which is exactly what we're
doing we've employed significant
deployed significant resources here uh
to be able to recover the on the object
as well as diplomatic and international
engagements going on to find more
information and again Solutions on this
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's February 16 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
uh subscribe to all the appropriate
places if you have not and if you want
to join us for the post game show
reubenreport.locals.com and it is
Thursday so we are doing a Community Q a
uh I will take an extra question or two
today that you throw in live during the
show and the only way to do that is on
locals so you can join right now get us
your thoughts they will come to me
through the internet Airwaves it's wild
the technology that we've got these days
uh before we get to the Q a though there
was a video that was making the rounds
that I wanted to talk about because I
think it hits on so many of the themes
that we talk about here mostly on the
cultural side but but sort of
politically as well Chelsea Handler who
I'm sure most of you have heard of she
is a comedian and I use air quotes
around the word comedian there she's
mostly a hysterical leftist activist
list her last stand-up comedy tour
which I saw the sign for I was at the
Hard Rock Cafe Hard Rock Hotel in
Hollywood California I was having some
drinks with friends having a lovely
evening and then this digital giant
billboard of her face popped up and it
said Chelsea Handler vaccinated and
horny to her and I almost burfed it was
horrible anyway she's sort of sort of
one of these crazy leftists everyone get
backs everyone's a racist and a bigot
you know whatever she happens to have
she's never gotten married okay that's
fine she's never had kids that's also
fine but she put out this video uh this
Tick Tock video about a day in the life
of a childless woman and there was all
sorts of Internet conversation as
happens on the interwebs about it take a
look at this and then we'll show you one
or two other things this is a day in the
life of a childless woman I wake up at
6am I remember that I have no kids to
take to school so I take an edible
masturbate and go back to sleep I wake
up at 12 30 pm and get ready for a busy
day of doing whatever the I feel
like I put on my most impractical and
stylish shoes since I won't be chasing a
child around the grocery store I go to
my fav spot in Paris to grab a croissant
I do a meditation sesh on the plane
since I have no screaming kids allowing
me all the Time in the World to become
enlightened the weightlessness of my
existence has granted me superhuman
Powers I teleport myself back home then
I get ready for a night out with
whatever hot guy I met on Raya that
morning I call up a babysitter and tell
her that I don't need her since I still
don't have kids now it's time for a
workout so I hit Mount Everest for a
quick climb I invent a time machine go
back in time and kill Hitler crazy
bastard it's amazing what you can do
when you have this much free time okay
so this video made the rounds and it got
people talking about having children or
not having children women of a certain
age
etc etc now it's interesting because
just purely at a comedy level usually
with comedy what you're trying to do is
say something true and you want to get
as close to that line of Truth while
also making people laugh and then they
can start thinking things for themselves
what's interesting about what she did
there was none of the things that she
says there are things that she does on a
given day except I would accept
masturbate and sleep as the two that she
probably does every day oh no eat an
edible she says eat an edible so I'll
give her that one let's count the ones
she eats an edible I'll give her that
she masturbates I'll give her that she
sleeps I'll give her that she Fancy
Shoes all right so so fresh she's four
for four I'm being a little harsher then
she claimed to go to Paris uh the
meditation I'm guessing she doesn't do
much of that she went to the Louvre
apparently he
um she teleported somewhere she gets
banged goes to Mount Everest time
machine Bubba okay without getting lost
in all of my new shows all this stuff
the point is that what she's showing you
there is that all these things that she
can do for purely for herself are
actually what's making her happy and
what a lot of people were responding to
on that is like it's like lady you
obviously don't do all of those things
right and do you actually seem happy
like you've become very rich doing what
you want to do I don't begrudge anyone
becoming rich obviously I don't begrudge
anyone doing whatever it is that they
feel that they should do in their life
but there there is
it seems to me that there is a slight
difference between men and women when
having children and I say this with a
certain sense of as a new father like I
now am well aware of the of the joys of
fatherhood and the struggles and all of
those things as well but that it seems
fundamentally more
uh almost almost
impossibly difficult for a woman to live
a fully actualized life without children
that isn't to say you cannot of course
but she's sort of Faking this thing like
you see how happy I am I get to do all
of this stuff for me you suckers have to
chase your kids and you don't get to
wear fancy high heels etc etc but the
interesting thing about this is she
frames it all in the idea that if you
just live for yourself and do whatever
it is you want or make up things that
you're doing because she's not really
doing all those things that somehow you
will be happy and that if you raise
children and you actually make your life
about bringing another life into this
world and doing some work related to
that that will somehow make you unhappy
and that's actually basically counter to
almost everything that humans have
learned about the course of Life over
the past several thousand years so
anyway she got some pushback on it and
then she pushed back on the pushback
she's guest hosting the Daily Show right
now I don't know if you remember but The
Daily Show was at one time a show that
people watched when Jon Stewart was host
they gave it to this Trevor Noah guy he
wrecked it then they finally separated
ways they fired him obviously and now
they've just been rolling out guest host
after guest house they and they just
can't get anyone funny right they just
cannot get anyone funny to do this
because it's left this dribble which is
the reverse of Comedy anyway she went on
The Daily Show to address the blowback
to her little Tick Tock video
thing that I have made abundantly clear
is that I do not want children I say it
on stage I say it in interviews it's the
first thing I say to myself in the
mirror when I wake up each morning right
before I tell myself God you're a
dynamic woman
thank you
kids don't respect me and quite frankly
the feeling is mutual and the fact is
there are millions of women just like me
but for some reason every single one of
us at some point in our lives is shamed
by Society for not wanting a baby but
these Fox News trolls are right about
one thing I am miserable in fact I was
just scrolling through my Instagram feed
the other day realizing how miserable I
am I'm miserable on the beach
and then here I am miserable on the top
of a mountain
and then here I am miserable scuba
diving
and then I'm miserable again smoking a
joint in a hot tub
every day is truly a new circle of hell
for me
the simple truth is that I'm not having
a kid because I'm happier without them
and that's really not of anyone's
concern but my own
and no I don't hate kids I just don't
want them that's what's so great about
nieces and nephews I love being an aunt
I'm crushing that role guess who gave
each one of them their first edible this
girl
yeah so she is the one who drugged her
nieces and nephews that's pretty
rewarding
my nephew was here a couple weeks ago I
was teaching him a mean crossover
dribble I didn't think of drugging him
but you know I'm old school uh anyway
she is right to some extent that it's
nobody's business but her own but she is
a public person who put this video out
here and now she's getting blowback in
that uh she comes from parents who
decided to have children like it's it's
the thing in life that keeps everything
going and you kind of don't know why
you're doing it she also seems to think
that people with children can't go to
the beach or can't do any of these
activities
I've been to the beach I may go to the
beach this weekend and I'm pretty sure
my kids have coveted but we're going to
get out there because the beach seems
like a good place to be when they do
anyway related to all of this you may
remember about gosh it's got to be about
eight months or so ago I went on Jordan
Peterson's new daily wire show it was
the first episode of the show and we
talked all about parenting and in in a
certain sense we were talking about gay
parenting and the challenges
specifically related to that but then we
broadened it to to what the purpose of
parenting is all together somebody put
together this nice uh minute-long little
uh snippet of that chat with Jordan
when you have a a baby say it's you
can't believe it
and you can't believe that you're going
to be able to figure out what to do with
this thing like it's like it's the most
complicated thing you've ever had and no
one has helped you figure out how to do
it
so you're stuck
and then like three months later it's
like you can't really imagine what life
would be like without that baby and then
it's sort of like this goes on forever
that's how it feels but it doesn't right
you have little kids for four years
so you miss it at your peril and you
don't get it back and that's not I know
what with your career you miss
opportunities you fall behind this
happens to women a lot it's part of the
reason for the pay Gap and it's really
hard on women you know although no one
knows what to do about it for women it
often seems that no matter what they do
it's wrong right they stay home with the
kids it's wrong if they go to work it's
wrong if they do both it's wrong and I'm
like I'm not being smart about that
that's rough man but I but having said
all that I would say again
you got little kids for four years
don't miss it you will regret it
which one of those Rings more true to
you what Jordan just said there
or what Chelsea Handler was saying
previously like you all just kind of
fundamentally know it I am in no way
mocking people that don't have children
I had 46 years on this Earth without
children I probably should have done it
earlier and we've rushed to have two
quickly because I wanted to be able to
play catch with them before I'm too old
you know what I mean
um but there is something bizarrely
connected to modern feminism and this
thing that we should only go for
happiness and it's all about us and
there isn't anything grander and we
should throw away all the things of the
past and then at the end is it leading
someone like her to happiness like I get
she has a lot of money and she can smoke
a joint in a hot tub and Drug her nieces
and nephews and things of that nature
and that's all well and good but that
there perhaps is something more
important here about The Human
Experience going on anyway it was
causing a real uh Firestorm on the
internet I wanted to give my two cents
on that I would love to hear your
thoughts so I'll take a look in the post
game show we'll discuss it uh on the
locals crew with the locals crew and
let's get to the Community Q a uh
McQuade says seeing how we're in a proxy
war against Russia is it too far of a
stretch to believe the D.C Democrats who
are currently pulling strings are timing
an eventual U.S military troop conflict
with Russia officially bringing our
nation into a state of War before the
2024 election first off I completely
agree with you we are in a proxy war we
have not declared war we often do
military Adventures without declaring
war the the most fun one for me remember
when we when Obama had us bombing Libya
and he didn't have to go to Congress
because he said it wasn't a war it was a
kinetic military action it was an Xbox
kinetic military action uh so cut this
is what we do we bomb Syria we bomb
countries all over the world and we say
oh these aren't specific War things I'm
fairly certain if somebody from say
across the world bombed us we might say
it's a war although we did just have a
Chinese spy balloon here and we didn't
say that was a war so who knows these
topsy-turvy times that we live in but
yes we are in some sort of proxy war if
for no other reason than we are funding
it we have given Ukraine a hundred
billion dollars we have no idea where
that money is we have no idea what it's
been spent on it obviously is a giant
money laundering scheme uh but your
question
is do you think that the Dems will ramp
this thing up before 2024. look at
wartime people reflexively vote for the
incumbent because you everything's crazy
the nuclear bomb could be dropped and
you're scared and we can't go through a
regime change in the middle of that
it'll be too scary
so yes I think there is a chance that
the war will go hot before then like I
don't know exactly what I mean by hot
but again you push Putin to the Limit
he has nukes so all of these people
every day along the path of this war
their people have been saying if we just
give him more tanks if we just give him
more planes if he just has more cash if
he just has more this or that and at the
end he's got the Ultimate Weapon
at the end he's got the Death Star right
and we've got some death stars too
that could end up very horribly so I
don't know what they would do I you know
the the counter argument to that
obviously is that if this thing keeps
getting ramped up and people start
seeing boy this Administration really
bungled this whole thing then that does
hurt the Dems in the in the next
election cycle so we shall see uh Quinn
says I've been working hard lately and
haven't been able to keep up with the
daily episodes would you consider doing
a weekly edit wrap-up of key segments
maybe one from the show and one from the
post show segments thanks for the
consideration
well Connor are you looking for more
work
Brock all right we're going to flip a
coin later and see if someone is willing
to do a little more work my guys are
seriously overloaded at the moment those
of you that are in the locals Community
you know were hiring an intern we're
going to actually pay we pay for interns
I don't believe in slave labor or
abusing young people unlike Chelsea
Handler
um but uh I think I actually do think
that's an interesting idea like sort of
a weekly recap kind of thing
um so stay tuned stay tuned on that and
if you want to send a resume over to the
Reuben report uh if you're just whatever
it is intern you got some skills you're
dedicated you want to live in Florida
you're a good human being jobs at
reubenreport.com uh Kathy says Dave what
would you and David like us to pray for
you and the boys today I do frequently
pray the prayer of protection Psalm 91
over you and your family wow that's very
kind of you uh well right now we just
the prayer protection probably would
work uh David has covid the kids likely
have covid you know the thing with the
kids in covid you're really supposed to
stick the freak can swab up their nose
to get the snot these kids are snotty
and gooey and yeah it's like a lot of
Goo everywhere but you don't want to
stick a swab up the kids know so we've
sort of just agreed it's kind of
irrelevant whether they technically have
covet or not but we do know that David
has it for some reason I'm fine
um whatever it is what it is I drink a
little water in the morning I always
feel like that probably does a little
you know I get up brush my teeth have a
little water I feel like that's like the
key to the whole operation here
um so we could use I guess a prayer for
just continued Health he's he's busting
his butt down there because you know
when I'm up here uh doing the show and
doing other TV things and everything
else like he has no help down there so
if there's a lot going on down there but
the second the show's over I throw on a
ratty ass t-shirt and I'm down there
getting spit up on everything else
Justin and Luke are doing a bit better
right now it's it's mostly David but we
go we got to get him right I'm sure
he'll be fine he'll be fine uh Nick says
uh what are your thoughts on Spencer
clavin's conspiracy theory
that gay Pete is actually a closeted
heterosexual who is trying to check a
box
well hold on let's let's see that's an
interesting Theory why don't we all
Close Our Eyes For a Moment
okay now picture gay Pete
now picture him banging it chick
is this working for anyone
I like you all close your eyes that was
good it's not working for anybody nobody
can picture gay Pete banging a chick so
that's an interesting Theory by Spencer
no I do believe he's gay which who I
just could not care less I could not
care less can you do your job I don't
care who you sleep with can you do your
job are you a competent individual
worthy of the position you've been put
in
but wouldn't that be funny I mean that
will happen soon enough like you know
it's happening soon enough the more they
go for these diversity hires people are
like oh yeah in college I hooked up with
the dude once I'm bi curious so give
make me president
uh chef says how do you and David
decompress
um it's gotten a little more difficult
for sure right like the kid thing does
change things so like in the old days
pre-kids when we were living that
Chelsea Handler life you know I could be
lounging in the pool on a Saturday you
know with a little little Tequila drink
you know just enjoying myself like that
like that sort of thing is gone now at
the at least temporarily right
um how do we well right now at the end
of the day the kids now actually are
like almost synced up with the Sleep
situation so by like 7 30 they're pretty
much out I always try I'm doing most of
the cooking these days David's a great
chef but I've really taken over in that
department and I love it because I'm not
looking at my phone I'm not paying
attention to anything else made a really
great uh skirt steak last night with
some potatoes and some salad
um so we try to I always set the table
like actual placemat cloth napkin like I
try light a candle like little music
like try to have some kind of normalcy
at that point and then and then if
they're actually sleeping we try to
watch something we just started the last
of us which is on HBO it is uh it's a
new zombie movie uh show it's sort of
like you know it's a little bit like
walking dead a little bit like Resident
Evil uh watched episode got through
episode three last night so I'm enjoying
that so far yeah so it's usually that
sort of thing almost every episode of
anything that we watch I fall asleep on
the couch and then I have to pick it up
before he starts the next day and we
rinse and recycle and do it over again
uh surris and also we take walks every
morning that actually is the the
decompress thing like we wake up and as
long as the weather is fine which it's
really been great like we get the kids
out on a walk it was really nice and
crisp today in the air and yeah that
that always helps uh
Sarah says Dave if DeSantis would become
president do you have concerns about the
direction of Florida in light of the
influx of New Yorkers and Californians
that could potentially change the red
and vote in a progressive you know I
don't really have that concern here I
have met so many people
so many people who are the the new
refugees into Florida and everyone
now I get it a self-selected group of
people are the type of types that come
up to me if I'm out in the store or
whatever but everybody seems to get it I
talk to all of all of the people that
I'm working with whether it's my
landscaper or electrician or plumber or
whatever
a waitress I talk and like everyone's
kind of feeling good about this place so
it really I see in years past before
kovid when people moved around the
country people moved because oh I got a
job in a new place you know I want to be
in slightly better weather something
like that and they didn't fully connect
the politics to why they were moving we
now know that quite literally millions
of people have migrated across the
country because of covid related
policies and how bad things are in blue
States and of course contrasting that
with how good things are in red States
so I really do think people get it so
I'm not too worried about that you know
the other thing here in Florida is that
his win was so massive 20 points that
something like that doesn't get degraded
over one election cycle or even two
election Cycles they've got majorities
on both sides of the house I think
they're absolutely whether he runs for
president or not they're talking about
what that bench looks like like who
comes after him how do we continue all
the success here so I'm not particularly
worried about that but as I've said the
last couple days the the thing that I am
somewhat concerned about is if he goes
and you know he gets into this blowout
with Trump and Trump just does all of
the most evil stuff imaginable and then
let's say DeSantis doesn't get the
nomination or gets the nomination and
loses which would be like really
unimaginable does he come back here and
then he's irreparably damaged and he's
and he's just a good guy and I you know
my feelings on that you we should help
good people when they get in the fight
so there are some concerns there but
um I think he has to do what he thinks
is right and I think the people of
Florida are already doing that in their
actions and their voting so I think
we're going to be okay Kevin says how
cool do you feel watching Jordan and
Victor on a podcast and JP is wearing a
tie with your name on it I think we have
a picture of this thing so this is
Jordan obviously that's Jordan Peterson
and there's this artist Jordan had told
me about this a couple weeks ago that
sent him a bunch of ties and pocket
squares and uh I think some some other
things uh some other pieces of fabric
with a whole bunch of the the
intellectual dark web crew uh Victor
Davis Hansen was the guest that he was
on with and I don't know how if Jordan
intentionally folded it that way or what
but if you look at his pocket square
that's the Reuben right there and I
think I'm on the tie as well and a
couple other I think the weinsteins are
on there I think Rogan is on there and a
few other people yeah that's I mean it's
pretty cool it's weird I'll tell you
it's weird like things like that happen
or even this nonsense that's going on
with News Guard right now where I'm I
mean News Guard is literally trying to
cancel the show right now and this is a
company that is this is a company it is
a non-profit funded by the government
and and Lefty agents that is in cahoots
with the world economic forum and
they're literally coming after me right
now I tweeted out a video this morning I
mean they work with the world economic
Forum you could imagine after what I've
been saying about the world economic
forum for the last month they would not
be thrilled with me but then I see these
things like we get emails from newsguard
or someone writes like a piece about me
and I'm like boy if you just read all
this nonsense you'd think that Dave
rubin's a real dick but it's just it's
just not true so it's all it's all kind
of funny but it's nice when it shows up
in a cool piece of art or clothing or
something like that uh Jeff says what
are your thoughts on Nikki Haley's
announcement and her presidential
campaign so far so first off I I really
like Nikki Haley I know that amongst the
bass especially the most Trump uh base
there seems to be some anger over Nikki
Haley which mostly stems from right
after January 6th that they felt that
she did not defend Trump the way that
she should so let's just put that over
here for a second in terms of everything
that she's done in her career she was an
unbelievably successful governor of
South Carolina like there's just no
doubt about that like South Carolina
even now is flourishing in large part
because of her most people most sane
people would agree with that there's
this feeling also from the base that
she's more of a neocon she's a war
Monger except uh I don't know what wars
she's been for she actually actually was
the U.S ambassador to the UN under
Donald Trump who was fighting for all of
Donald Trump's America First policies
and she was our U.N Ambassador as all of
these deals uh these peace deals were
being signed in the Middle East and
everything else I also know her a bit
personally we've had dinner a few times
she's she's just a lovely person so I
don't know what all the the animosity is
towards her but I think she would
certainly be a great part of any
Administration and and I think that
getting more people in is good you know
if at the end of the day we have 10
people and like look what the Democrats
put up last time right between between
Pete and you know Bernie the Socialist
and then Elizabeth Warren the other
socialist and who was the woman with the
crystals and the Rocks Marianne
Williamson like these bananas people and
then everyone knew that the main guy had
dementia like look at that clown show of
people they put up there if the
Republicans come out this time and let's
let's assume uh putting aside some of
Trump's Behavior lately like so you get
Trump okay you get DeSantis okay you get
Nikki Haley maybe you get Tim Scott you
maybe get a couple other people and then
it starts looking like a decent group of
people and maybe we all have some policy
disagreements but these people aren't
bananas they don't hate and want to
disassemble America so I I think there's
a rich opportunity there I think there
may be another question about that uh so
I'll pause for just a moment uh Florida
man Chuck says who is your favorite
Golden Girl and why I believe I've
addressed this once or twice on the show
but but Dorothy was born act played by
Bea Arthur was my favorite Golden Girl
first off you could I go in phases is
with all the Golden Girls
um and actually to get to a question
from earlier one of the things we do to
decompress Sundays it's gotten a little
harder with the kids now
but because we can't just be outlounging
in the pool we just throw on Hulu I'll
just pick a random season The Golden
Girls and we'll we'll kind of watch in
and out for a couple hours just it's
just comedy Perfection 1985 to 1992
seven seasons of Brilliance and I in my
opinion the show got better each season
along I think season seven is As Good As
It Ever Was if not better than it ever
was but Dorothy Dorothy was the
conscience of the group she was sort of
the sane one right so Blanche was the
Rose was kind of the Sophia
was the quippy one Dorothy was sort of
the same glue of the whole thing and
there's an episode I've described it on
the show once or twice before where she
describes herself I think she even says
she's a classical liberal or an old
school liberal because she's arguing
with Stan her ex-husband's cousin Magda
who's coming from the Czech Republic a
communist country and she's talking
about how America has too many choices
and Dorothy defends America and and
liberalism and all of those the
liberalism in the right sense of
liberalism uh and also Dorothy like
she's just uh they're just an incredible
actress I mean the side eye that she
could give like just that pause just
just perfect the valencias say do you
think Trump's campaign may have been
infiltrated by Democrat operatives the
absolute ridiculous and strategically
moronic things he has said of late on
DeSantis are just mind-boggling it's not
like there is not a precedent set on him
allying himself with buffoons in his
inner circle yeah so look again and I'll
keep saying this and you know we're
reaching out to the Trump people right
now because I would love to sit down
with him I'll gladly go there to do it
and all of those things there is a
chance I will be voting for him but the
behavior over the last couple weeks just
sitting at Mar-A-Lago like are you
building out a team who who is the team
you announced two months ago so who have
you hired what is your team or are you
just gonna sit there and put things on
Truth social you know calling them
around the sanctimonious and going after
the guy who hasn't even announced and
calling him a rhino and a globalist and
it's like well you did support him twice
for governor and credit your self for
getting him elected and all of those
things it's like I just don't think that
thing's going to work anymore I think
we're past it I think that most of us
just want competency and decency and I
think that that's why DeSantis has
played this thing so well putting aside
that I like the guy he is just governing
for the people and he's not getting
involved in all the nonsense right they
ask him well Trump said this about you
and he's like look I'm I'm going to get
attacked but I'm here to govern I'm here
to do the right thing by by the
Floridians and I think that's the right
move on this thing I I don't know that
the
the game that thing that the trolling
game and that thing which which we've
all enjoyed to some degree and it was
necessary to expose a lot of the system
it was necessary to show what Hillary
Clinton was and all that stuff I just
don't know that it's going to work this
time and I certainly don't know that
it's going to work on a guy like
DeSantis who really has been the
standard Bearer for what's been right in
America politically over the last couple
years like all you're going to do that
just because you think you have to be
president like I don't I don't know that
that's willing to work but your question
was do I think Democrats have
infiltrated the campaign I mean I have
no evidence of that specifically I think
it is possible that that to some degree
Trump is losing a little bit of his uh
his Magic Touch related to what people
want you know he's been off Twitter for
so long he's doing the truth thing and
Truth has great uh traction for sure
truth social has we post on Truth social
it's got great traction but he's only
getting the base there and I think maybe
what's happening is that that when
you're only hearing the response from
the base or you're only hanging out at
Mar-A-Lago and people are only coming to
see you all time meaning you're not on
the road as much you're not around First
Responders or military people or just
the average mom and pop you know he used
to just show up at things all the time
and get huge Applause you don't go to
stadiums anymore sports game and be
cheered on I think maybe he's losing his
touch for a little bit of that stuff and
and I actually say all of this with uh
I say love I don't know if it's love but
I say it all with like
we don't have to do this man like the
burn down thing we don't have to do
there might be a way to to work together
here but he's throwing the kitchen sink
out right now it might be a little bit
early for that uh Sam says what is your
favorite TV episode of all time
I could give you many episodes of The
Golden Girls I could give you many
episodes of Seinfeld however
I think the best episode of Television
ever
was a show on HBO probably this has got
to be around 2002 to
2009 maybe something like that get me
the years on this show
um Six Feet Under on HBO did any of you
guys watch 1600 it's a little bit before
your time man uh it was an absolutely
wonderful show about a family who owned
a mortuary and every episode it was on
Sunday nights every episode began with
somebody a random character dying and
then they would in essence have to deal
with the funeral of that person uh in
each episode but then you'd really learn
a whole bunch more about the family and
it was UN like this guy I think Alan
Ball was the creator and the director
and he had he's the guy that did
American Beauty which was also which was
a wonderful wonderful movie uh about 20
some odd years ago uh but what was it
was just like an unbelievably human
painful like you'd be crying and
laughing at the exact same time and for
those of you that remember the episode
uh the final episode they they do what a
lot of TV shows have subsequently done
to end the show a whole bunch of shows
have done this since where they just
flash forward for the next like 50 years
they just show you what happens to all
of the people they show all of the
characters that you've loved over those
years aging and dying and what happens
to their life and they do it with a
beautiful song by uh is it Mia or I
forget what her name was but really
great you could even if you haven't
watched the show you could probably
appreciate if you just Google six feet
under last episode or last few minutes
it's it's just absolutely wonderful uh
talway says other oh and the show was on
HBO from 2001 to 2005. uh tawei says
other than Trump Haley and DeSantis who
else do you see as a strong Republican
presidential candidate for 2024.
um well I think Mike Pompeo who I
interviewed a couple weeks ago I was
pretty impressed by him you know look
the guy's got a great pedigree head of
the CIA former Secretary of State I'm
not on board award some of his Ukraine
stuff because he really just wanted to
just keep arming Ukraine like we have to
just arm them to defeat Russia I just
don't see that as something but he
clearly has a wide breadth of knowledge
I was really uh I thought he was kind of
pleasant like bizarrely Pleasant I
didn't know if he was going to be like
kind of gruff or whatever but we chatted
for a little bit before the Skype
session you know before we started
recording was kind of fun and funny and
he watches the show and he knew things
about me just struck me as a nice guy
um I think maybe Tim Scott could get
involved which would be great then we'd
have two South Carolinians uh going for
it who else might get involved I mean
there's always oh well now I'm hearing
that uh Vivek ramaswamy is gonna run
that seems to be something that people
are talking about you guys Vivek has
been on the show I've done some events
with him over the years he's uh he is a
VC guy worth couple hundred million
bucks who's really fighting ESG and
making sure that this
nonsensical diversity equity and
inclusion memo that has now infected all
of these companies he's working to
really get that out will would a guy
like him become president probably not
his best his best sort of Runway with it
would be that he'd become like a Ross
perotype but he might help get some of
those ideas out there and that is good
and then of course the other guy that
apparently is running I don't know
anything officially yet but I'll text
him after the show uh is Larry Elder has
been hinting at it for quite some time
and Larry again it's like I don't know
that he would become president right
like the top tier guys you've got your
Trump your DeSantis I think you could
probably put Nikki Haley in there maybe
one or two other people but then there's
a bunch of other people that run and
then it helps get ideas out there and
that is worth it right that absolutely
is worth it uh Rand Paul has run for
president I think twice and just by
getting on the stage it helps strengthen
some libertarian ideas so you know
running is also a bit of jockeying for
position you know somebody might be
running because they they don't fully
think they're going to become president
but they'd like to be in an
Administration or they'd like to be VP I
mean these are all the games that that
gets played throughout a campaign uh
Fred says what are your thoughts on
James O'Keefe possibly being removed by
project Veritas or from Project Veritas
by the board so if you didn't hear about
this you know a couple weeks ago there
was this unbelievable project Veritas
video where they basically do their
Guerrilla filming and they get a
executive at Pfizer to admit that not
only are they doing gain of function
research but like they're doing it at a
very sort of scary level fully and fully
because they just want to put more
vaccines out there to make more money
all hell broke loose we showed you the
guys the video and I'm sure most of you
have seen it anyway anyway about two
weeks later after this crazily viral
video I mean the thing got seen at least
30 million times suddenly they announced
that uh James O'Keefe that I think 16
employees had said he was harassing them
and a whole bunch of other stuff it
sounded like he was going to get fired
but I'm I'm told he is staying on his
head yeah so he is staying on his head
of veritas they'll have to do some
internal cleanup of their stuff look as
long as he didn't break the law
um you know he treated employees poorly
you would hope that he would not do that
but now hopefully they have an HR
department and they'll deal with that
sounds like maybe he was spending some
of the cash on on you know like fancy
hotel rooms and things like that like
you got to clean up that but that's HR
stuff to deal with but as long as you
know he didn't doctor a video you know
do something that was completely against
the mission of project Veritas then I
think you give the guy a second chance
so it sounds like that's what the board
is going to do there and that that seems
pretty solid to me Curtis says Dave in
raising your boys would you focus on
Jordan Peterson's tenant the pursuit of
happiness is a pointless goal yeah and
I've really come around on that one I've
really come around on that one people
always say as long as you're happy do
whatever you want as long as you're
happy and it doesn't really make sense
it's like most of the things that we get
what do I always say about the left like
you just have to listen to them for one
second and then you just peel off that
that quick veneer of what sounds right
and then you find underneath it is
something much much worse your your goal
should not be happiness happiness should
be a a sidebar a valuable sidebar to
something that gives you purpose there
is something in every single person
every single one of you watching this
there is something that you have that
you want to do
and you must try to do it I think you
have to try to do it because if you try
to do it a you might get it and the
process of trying to get it whether
whether it's I want to build cars I want
to be a stand-up comedian whatever the
hell it is you want to do like you have
some opportunity to go get it and the
adventure of getting it is what makes
you a strong full person and then you
will find happiness within that but if
you say my goal is just to be happy
whatever that means first off it's
ridiculously amorphous right my goal is
just to be happy well what does that
mean my goal is to have a yacht my goal
is to do all of the things that Chelsea
Handler said she was doing every morning
which she actually isn't doing like will
that just bring you my my goal is just
to get pleasure all the time I like
pleasure but it can't be the only driver
of what you do so uh yeah I hope that we
actually Dave and I did talk about it
for about a half hour last night because
they they suddenly do seem like they're
getting a bit older and we're like holy
cow like this this really is going to
happen fast and we were talking about
how like you know it will be our job to
to send these kids out into the world
like in a somewhat sensible way and God
only knows where the world will be in 18
years like when we're like passing them
off to the world and it's like hopefully
we will have done a decent enough job
that whether the metaverse has taken
over or the zombie apocalypse is here or
maybe things got corrected
and will have given them all the tools
to go into a corrected world that they
can do awesome awesome things in like
any of those things are possible but I
don't think the goal should be you well
just go be happy it just doesn't mean
anything it actually it's the reverse of
what the point of it all is the point is
purpose find something you want to do
and again you may not accomplish that
exactly but that challenge and going
through that thing trust me there were
plenty of times over the years when when
I was doing stand-up and I was on the
road and like I was broke and just like
it just was not working you know what I
mean it had nothing to do with not being
good or anything like that like it's
it's just hard to do anything that's
worth doing everyone would want to be a
TV personality or a like everyone would
want to be a basketball player or a
football player but it's hard as hell to
do but I don't think anyone who has even
the guys that don't make it take a guy
you could take a guy that's like like
we'll do a sports version of this you
know a he's a pretty solid basketball
player plays him College really wants to
get to the NBA never makes it to the NBA
maybe he makes it to the CBA or I don't
even know if that exists anymore but
like a lower league or he plays in
Europe and he bounces around and he
never does it and now he's 37 and he's
on the other he's older now and he's got
to retire and find something else to do
do you think at the end of giving if he
gave it his all like really gave it his
all you think at the end he's like man I
shouldn't have done that
I don't think so I don't think so and I
think that that's probably the purpose
of all of this Tony says recently I've
been watching old videos of Craig
Ferguson reminiscing of the days when
late night TV was actually funny do you
think in the coming years we will see a
return to normalcy in comedy and
entertainment these woke companies can
only lose money for so long before they
go completely irrelevant I certainly
hope so and you know I've been saying
how I've been watching old Johnny Carson
videos I've had Phoenix watching some
old Johnny Carson stuff I I would love I
mean we've been talking about maybe
doing some kind of other late night
thing live studio audience thing so
we're thinking about that that is the
one thing that I miss when I'm when I'm
just in here talking to the camera like
I do miss that interaction and that's
why I love going on the road so much and
I also am watching I'm watching a whole
bunch of old stuff lately like that
that's been my thing I watched the this
is going to date me now
I watched the last episode of The Carol
Burnett Show last night uh the show was
on for for 11 years give me the years on
The Carol Burnett Show I'm going to say
it was probably about
77 to 80. eight no no no no it's got to
be earlier than that 71 to 82 something
like that
how am I doing yeah we're gonna find it
The Carol Burnett Show um and you know
she did all these amazing sketches and
she would walk out in front of the crowd
first and she would take some questions
and it was I just always I just always
really enjoyed her man I was way off 67
to 78. jeez that was a long time ago
um but I do find that watching some of
those old things I've watched a couple
Dick Cavett interviews I watched one of
uh Lucille Ball the other day you know
there's something there was something
good in television it's very easy for us
to all be like ah Hollywood's just all
awful and it was always all awful and
everything else but it really wasn't
like you watch Johnny Carson interview
Carl Sagan in 1978 and and talk about
philosophy and talk about astronomy and
and extraterrestrials and it was
thoughtful and it was interesting it's
only in this last I don't know it could
be 20 years but it's really exacerbated
obviously in the last 10 years where it
became hyper partisan and overly
produced and slick and gross and where
you turn on late night TV where you used
to you know a guy like Jay Leno you
didn't really know his political
opinions but you knew it was kind of
light and most likely you could fall
asleep watching it and not feel
hysterical right where now it's like you
turn on you know Fallon or Kimmel or one
of these other clowns and they're
demanding you all get faxed and it's
like why the hell would you go to sleep
watching that like why would you do it
to yourself so I do think there will be
a comeback this is part of why
it's part of why we started locals it's
part of why we're doing what we're doing
with Rumble we need new everything right
like people are tuning out of those
things they really really are it's why I
constantly I would say the one struggle
I have doing this show which I'm I
freaking love today more than than ever
like I love what we're doing and the
numbers are proving it out and all those
things but there's always this constant
struggle between okay should I address
what's going on on MSNBC and CNN and the
lunacy of the view or do we just
completely go our other way and I what
I've tried what we've sort of internally
discussed is that we have to address it
to some degree because we still have to
save people there aren't enough of us
yet that have been red pilled on that
stuff to just completely ignore it as if
it has no relevance but my goal would be
that we do this long enough and we keep
going and going and going and building
something great that hopefully is a
little bit closer to the truth and and
that those things will continue to
crumble and that will have paved a road
for the people that are finally like
every day I just know it every day there
is someone that is watching The View
going this is not making
it then maybe somebody says to them have
you have you seen that Dave Rubin guy
you know his show's on at 11 A.M Eastern
too maybe you want to watch that or you
can watch it later because it's on the
computer machine and maybe check that
out and he's kind of doing uh the same
topics as the view but saying completely
different things about it you might find
that interesting I think we can keep
bringing those people over I don't think
they're bringing in new people who is
the young person that that is like you
know I'm 16 years old I'm going to watch
CNN and the view and learn about the
world like I don't think that person
exists but there is a 16 year old out
there who is watching this or 16 or out
year old out there who's watching Rogan
and it doesn't mean we're right about
all of these things right but like
the the shift has happened and we just
have to continue playing through and
continue fighting the world economic
forum and News Guard and the rest of the
awful human beings would like to stop us
on that note we will do a post game show
momentarily if you'd like to join us
it's at reubenreport.locals.com we'll
throw in a couple extra questions and
comments my full interview with Spencer
Clayman my buddy his new book came out
this week and uh we did about we did
like a half hour abbreviated version
It's called how to save the West uh that
is up right now across platforms my
interview with Pete bagozian who is a
lefty and still believes he is a good
liberal we both watch the state of the
union and saw it very very differently
so we decided to just do a sit down and
talk it out it's really interesting I
think you'll enjoy it we leave you with
a Kamala Harris cold close and I will
see no we're not doing a come out we're
doing the Joe Biden yeah we switched it
at the last second we leave you with the
Joe Biden cold close and I will see uh
the rest of you momentarily so here is
the God's truth close your eyes
[Music]
eyes
go on close your eyes just close your
close your eyes close your eyes mask you
ought to close your eyes close your eyes
close your eyes close your eyes close
your eyes close your eyes close your
eyes close your eyes close your eyes
[Music]
you guys remember what you saw on
television
[Music]
all right